[Musique]
madame monsieur bonjour et bienvenue
pour ce nouveau numéro de dimanche en
politique en direct sur france 3
bourgogne la gauche at-elle encore une
chance à l'élection présidentielle elles
se remettent à espérer mais elle peine à
trouver une unité on en parle ce matin
avec nos quatre invités stéphane guiguet
bonjour vous êtes vice président du
conseil régional premier secrétaire
fédéral du ps en saône-et-loire et vous
soutenez benoît hamon boris obama
bonjourbonjour candidats aux
législatives pour la france insoumise
je soutenais jean luc mélenchon claire
mallard bons joueurs candidate aux
législatives en saône-et-loire et pour
europe ecologie les verts vous soutenez
donc yannick jadot
et puis claire rocher bonjour dur porte
parole de lutte ouvrière vous soutenez
nathalie arthaud j'ajoute enfin que ce
cette émission est diffusée en direct
également sur notre page facebook vous
pouvez donc réagir et poser toutes les
questions que vous voulez alors cette
semaine les électeurs de la primaire
écologique ont voté massivement pour un
rapprochement des programmes entre
benoit amour yannick jadot et jean luc
mélenchon pour les deux premiers les
discussions devraient aboutir dans la
semaine nous dit on alors ça veut dire
que les écologistes claire mala accepte
de leur idée soit représentée par
quelqu'un d'autre
alors aujourd'hui ce qu'il faut
constater c'est que l'écologie a une
place importante dans cette campagne
qu'est ce que cela veut dire que ton
dont se réclame de l'écologie oui et
tant mieux c'est bien ça veut dire qu'il
ya une victoire culturelle de l'écologie
aujourd'hui à gauche et on ne peut que
se peut que s'en réjouir
notre responsabilité que ce soit jean
luc mélenchon benoît mme yannick jadot
et de construire une dynamique de de
créer un nouvel espoir pour faire gagner
l'écologie et la gauche en 2017
stéphane guiguet c'est quoi c'est de la
cuisine électorale
il se passe en ce moment donc je repasse
problème a été identifié très tôt dans
la primaire d'ailleurs arnaud montebourg
avait dit si je suis élue dès le
lendemain j'irai discuter avec monsieur
mélenchon et monsieur jadot donc ces
démarches est peu ou prou la même chez
benoît hamon et je crois que c'est une
démarche saine effectivement l'écologie
est au coeur du dispositif de
de la campagne électorale je crois que
benoît hamon a été identifié comme un
candidat sérieux sur la question avec
des propositions moderne en terme
d'écologie
donc je me félicite du vote d'europe
écologie les verts pour entamer une
discussion qui me paraît de bon aloi
pour la suite ce qui n'est peut-être pas
le cas dans tous les domaines en tout
cas pour l'écologie c'est le cas je vois
pas l'intérêt d'avoir une concurrence
sur ce thème là en tout cas pour une
offre politique qui est la même alors
brisé cette semaine alors jean-luc
mélenchon à dire beaucoup de choses
il a dit notamment qu'alors qu'il était
pour une candidature commune mais qu'à
condition que ce soit lui jeudi l'a
finalement détaillé des conditions dans
une lettre à benoît hamon qui finalement
hier il a dit qu'il voulait pas se
raccrocher un corbillard entre
guillemets le ps
franchement il fait tout pour faire
capoter les discussions non je ne suis
pas d'accord déjà tout d'abord jean luc
mélenchon ça a été le premier à tendre
la main à monsieur hamon monsieur hamon
avait bien dit qu'il allait parler un
jeu jean luc mélenchon il en a rien été
c'est jean luc mélenchon qui a écrit
cette lettre
la lettre dont vous dont venait de
parler ensuite vous avez demandé si
c'était un peu de la cuisine politique
moi je suis un petit peu surpris de la
stratégie un petit peu des verts qui ont
toujours été les premiers cocufié par le
parti socialiste de leur faire un chacun
un chèque en blanc de cette manière en
même temps quand ils ne passent pas
d'accord on l'a vu au conseil régional
il disparaît exactement donc c'est bien
pour ça que c'est plus de la survie que
une vision réelle sur un projet
collectif
nous ce qu'on propose c'est pas de la
tambouille c'est de se mettre d'accord
sur un certain nombre de points cruciaux
comment faire une nouvelle politique
avec madame l conneries avec monsieur le
guen avec madame marisol touraine etc
j'ai passé un an à manifester contre la
loi les conneries on ne me demande
aujourd'hui de mal hier madame l
conneries tout ça est tout simplement
ridicule
donc il faut un petit peu de cohérence
et c'est tout ce qu'on demande claire
rocher quel regard vous portez sur tout
ça pour vous mélenchon amont jadot c est
pareil au même
en tout cas moi je fais pas partie de
cette gauche de gouvernement qu'on a vu
depuis des années ou de ceux qui veulent
lui ressembler et
vernay parce que c'est une gauche qui a
toujours finalement servi la bourgeoisie
au gouvernement on l'a vu dans les cinq
années qu'on vient de passer avec 40
milliards faire au patronat à fonds
perdus moi je suis du camp des
travailleurs et ça veut dire bien autre
chose que ce que pourrait vouloir dire
la gauche unie ou pas sous ses diverses
d'étiquettes mais parce que nathalie
arthaud elle était très active 1 cette
semaine on l'a vu notamment je pense
qu'on va voir quelques images à tarbes à
poitiers à amiens à clermont elle disait
celui qui sortira des urnes sera
l'ennemi des travailleurs ça veut dire
que vous ne donner aucun crédit aux
candidats de gauche
aucun nom et puis c'est pas nous lutte
ouvrière qui leur donne aucun crédit ils
n'ont plus aucun crédit auprès des
travailleurs parce qu'on les a vus à
l'oeuvre
on les a vus finalement faire la part
belle à toutes les mesures dans le sens
des riches actuellement nous
travailleurs chômeurs gens des classes
populaires on est quand même face à une
guerre leur fortune privée énorme les
profits qu on jamais été aussi grand les
dividendes quand jamais été aussi
important c'est sur le recul de nos
salaires de nos retraites qui font cette
fortune là et donc on est soit dans un
camp soit dans l'autre et moi je suis du
camp des travailleurs de la france un
sony récuse les politiques qui ont été
menées depuis un certain nombre d'années
d'oncle vania king nous assimiler à ce
genre de politique mais écoutez jean luc
mélenchon il se pose comme un x6 m
sauveur suprême qui va tout changer une
fois qu'il sera au gouvernement
maintenant qu'est ce qu'ils proposent en
direction des travailleurs 1300 euros
mais 300 euros de servicemine de salaire
minimum c'est complètement insuffisant
par rapport à ce dont on a besoin et
pourquoi il propose pas plus mal parce
qu'il veut pas s'affronter à la
bourgeoisie ce soir prendre sur les
profits pour assurer les salaires qu'il
nous faudrait à savoir rien inférieurs à
ceux du satisfecit pour vivrières et la
france a soumis c'est que vous vous êtes
là à attendre le grand soir que les gens
se réveillent qui est une sorte de
révolution on l'attend toujours elle ne
viendra jamais nous on a un programme
qui essaye d'être cohérent on essaye de
faire des propositions qui sont
réalisables et nous sommes tout autant
que vous du côté des travailleurs ne
pouvez pas vous accaparer les
travailleurs ou les salariés stéphane
guiguet je ne pourrais pas après
jean-luc mélenchon a dit
hier benoît hamon vous avez l'impression
que l'ego puisqu'on en parle beaucoup de
jean luc mélenchon passe au dessus d'un
accord éventuel
on l'a compris gouvernement souhaitait
pas s'adresser uniquement à jean luc
mélenchon
sais tu ce cette problématique d'union
de la gauche et les primordial moi j'ai
vécu le 21 avril 2002 comme vous je ne
veux pas revivre ça on sera peut-être
pas d'accord sur les causes de ce 21
avril pour autant je crois qu'on
souhaite tous ne pas se retrouver dans
cette situation prochainement donc la
main a été tendue
il faut qu'elle soit saisie de façon
sincère elle l'a été du côté d'europe
écologie les verts
elle l'est également de la part d'un
certain nombre de communistes puisque
j'ai vu qu'il y avait des tribus qui a
été signé par un certain nombre de
communistes pour appeler à l'union de la
gauche donc je benoît hamon clairement
va va s'adresser maintenant aux
électeurs de gauche et c'est ça
l'essentiel c'est qu'on retrouve qu'on
retrouve sa et les propos que vous
évoquiez tout à l'heure sur le
corbillard je crois que c'est pas de
nature à apaiser le débat et je ne crois
pas que les français attendent que ça en
ce moment on n'a pas besoin
d'agressivité dans le débat public au
contraire je crois qu'on a besoin
ensemble collectivement d'être
intelligent alors justement il ya une
question d'un internaute qui nous disait
sur notre notre page internet montaigu
vous danser au bord du volcan
l'entreprise le pen n'a jamais été aussi
près du pouvoir en 2002 la gauche élargi
était déjà divisé alors est ce que vous
avez retenu la leçon
vous vous demandez ça avoue écologique
par exemple je vais rebondir
monsieur guiguet je pense que l'enjeu
aujourd'hui n'est pas de reconduire la
vieille gauche plurielle et
d'additionner les appareils mais c'est
de construire un vrai rassemblement
cohérent comme le dit monsieur obama sur
des points de convergence qui sont prêts
si on ne négociera pas il n'y aura pas
de compromis sur l'écologie notamment
sur la question énergétique sur le
renouvellement démocratique et sur la
refondation de l'europe
il faut dépasser des appareils dépasser
les parties rassembler et fédérer les
françaises sur ce projet d'espoir il y a
une grande espérance on peut faire
rempart un libéralisme débridé à un
nationalisme exacerbé
donc on a une responsabilité qui est
collective mais qui sera pas sur des
petits compromis
voilà l'enjeu voilà comment on se
positionne aujourd'hui j'entends bien la
petite musique le drapeau du front
national qui fait peur qu'on nous
ressort à chaque élection sauf qu'il me
semble
le réel a eu lieu et si le front
national est à fait mais le réel et luce
donc on est bien obligé de faire un peu
la généalogiste qui s'est passé la
question qu'on peut légitimement se
poser c'est pourquoi le front national
et il est aussi à ces duos politiques
ont été réalisés ces dix dernières
années par la droite et par parti
socialiste et notamment en 2005 quand la
démocratie par lesquelles est contre le
traité de lisbonne et qu'on le fait que
monsieur hollande et monsieur sarkozy le
fait passer c'est ça qui fait monter le
front national
donc à chaque fois nous dire oui il faut
faire attention le front national front
national moi je me suis engagé pour
faire la politique de manière positive
ce qui m'intéresse c'est la question de
partage des richesses la planification
et le écologique et l'urgence
démocratique la sixième république
instaurée une une assemblée constituante
et c'est donc la politique doit être
positif ne doit pas être contre quelque
chose simplement j'entends je re situer
un petit peu le contexte et je disais
que maintenant le fn avait une place
prégnante dans le débat politique
pour autant vous pouvez pas reprocher à
monsieur armand de ne pas développer un
certain nombre d'idées d'être
relativement est même plutôt critique
par rapport aux cinq années qui viennent
de se dérouler il a d'ailleurs pour des
raisons politiques et d'orientation
économique quitter le gouvernement avec
arnaud montebourg à une certaine période
puisque ça devenait plus supportable
pour lui d'être à l'intérieur de ce
gouvernement donc on est vraiment sur
les propositions et sur le contenu c'est
d'ailleurs comme ça que les électeurs de
gauche ont découvert monsieur armand à
travers cette primaire je regrette que
jean luc mélenchon et yannick jadot
n'est pas participation à cette primaire
dont acte maintenant qu'est ce qu'on
peut faire ensemble collectivement
intelligemment
alors justement benoît hamon était
vendredi et hier à bourg au portugal
pour prendre exemple sur 7 sur le
gouvernement portugais puisqu'il est
dirigé par l'ancien secrétaire général
du parti socialiste qui a le soutien de
la gauche radicale et des communistes la
gauche club ne peut pas exister vous
pour vous c'est inenvisageable ce genre
de choses qu'il a renchéri en tout cas
nous on en fait pas du tout partie
moi je suis du camp des travailleurs
vous savez il n'y aura pas de moins pire
pour les travailleurs tant qu'ils
retrouveront pas le chemin des luttes
collectives maintenant dans cette
élection présidentielle il ya aucune
raison de donner sa voix à quelqu'un
dont
c'est qu'au lendemain de l'élection il
va trahir toutes ses promesses parce que
il cédera aux diktats des financiers des
capitalistes et il fera finalement ce
que ce que les riches lui demanderont
dans cette élection les travailleurs ils
peuvent faire entendre leur intérêt
faire entendre leurs exigences à travers
la candidature de nathalie arthaud et je
pense que c'est la seule chose utile qui
est à faire dans cette élection
présidentielle mais elle est créditée de
0 5% nathalie arthaud pour l'instant
dans les sondages est ce que c'est
est ce que finalement en disant que
l'élection n'est pas un but en soi
vous ne devez pas un peu vos électeurs
je dis pas que c'est pas un but en soi
est d'ailleurs moi je souhaite qu'ils
aient le maximum de travailleurs
d'ouvriers de chômeurs qu'ils se fassent
entendre au travers de sa candidature
maintenant vous savez il faut pas
craindre d'être minoritaire parce que
être majoritaire pour élire un hollande
qui va gouverner contre vos intérêts on
a vu ce que ça donnait donc oui ça sera
un vote minoritaire mais ça sera un vote
de fierté ouvrière et sur nos
revendications et nos intérêts de
travailleurs ça comptera infiniment plus
que de déterminer qui sortira du chapeau
pour être président de la république
pour l'instant c'est marine le pen qui
se dit candidate du peuple
qu'est ce que ça vous inspire aux uns et
aux autres qui vous dites tous de gauche
parce que ça nous inspire c'est qu'il
faut reconstruire cette grande espérance
effectivement il faut quitter ce vieux
monde qui accaparent les richesses qui
creuse les inégalités qui détruit notre
environnement à des fins mercantiles et
le projet de yannick jadot et qui peut
être partagé et qui doit être partagée
par monsieur mélenchon par monsieur
hamon c'est de réparer cette société de
réparer de réparer cette société de
prendre soin des hommes des femmes et de
notre nature voilà c'est bien pour ça
que je pense que pour pouvoir battre
marine le pen s'est pas de
l'arithmétique qu'il faut faire en
additionnant les verts la france
insoumise où le parti socialiste
si on veut battre marine le pen il faut
proposer aux gens une vision un projet
collectif et c'est pourquoi ne pas en
parler ensemble
la seule chose que nous on dit cela ne
fera pas de chèque en blanc on a déjà
entendu les palaces du granger et qu'on
fera
on sera très vigilant sur beaucoup de
points pour l'instant elle
les enquêtes sont sont têtus vous tous
vos candidats sont éliminés au premier
tour donc qu'est-ce qui a pas obligation
de s'entendre il ya obligation de
construire une dynamique autour de
l'écologie qui porte un espoir et qui
peut rassembler et fédérer les français
et je crois que le message est là en
fait je devrais me guy le programme de
benoît hamon pour l'instant est tout à
fait dans cette ligne a c'est à dire
penser la société de demain
repenser le travail le rapport qu'on
peut avoir un travail le rapport à
l'écologie ne pas opposer
systématiquement la question sociale à
la question écologique les institutions
bien évidemment qui sont au coeur de des
préoccupations de benoît hamon
vers quel sixième république on va
puisque on sent bien manifestement qu'on
est au bout d'un système donc c'est sur
ces bases là que benoît hamon souhaite
dialoguer à la fois avec les verts à la
fois avec le front de gauche le parti
communiste et tous les partenaires pour
construire ensemble la victoire de 2 1
me suis dit vous parler du programme de
benoît hamon je les ai pas vus en fait
tu vois ce qu'il est le programme de
benoît hamon ce que nous on en a le
programme l'avenir en commun mais
monsieur law peu de monsieur hamon a
juste fait des propositions durant la
primaire il n'y a pas de programme c'est
aussi ça que nous on souhaite mettre
dans la balance
on va discuter autour de quoi la notion
d'éco d'écologie crucial mais moi en ce
moment en préparation avec sa
préparation mais effectivement il va
sortir au mois de mars et l'élection
présidentielle est quand même en avril
donc c'est plutôt quand même nous ça
fait un an qu'on prépare ça avec plus de
350 propositions des milliers de
personnes qui ont constitué ce programme
là donc effectivement nous nous on veut
bien discuter mais autour de quelque
chose de concret j'entends cette
caricature qui consiste à dire non au
monde propose rien vous vous devriez
puissant j'ai juste dit j'aimerais juste
voir et moi j'aimerais que tout le monde
se mette autour d'une table pour
effectivement qu'on puisse proposer un
programme commun à l'ensemble de la
gauche
je crois que c'est ça et l'avenir c'est
ça et moi je me suis réjoui de la
victoire de benoît hamon et
d'élimination de ce valse vous pouvez en
être sûr effectivement nous on fera pas
une nouvelle fois de chèque en blanc
parti socialiste on a déjà été déçus on
a déjà été trahie on va être très
vigilants et il vit il faut pas non sera
dans ce débat-là mettre de l'agressivité
je crois une je crois que les mots ont
été employés pour un homme qui prétend
accéder aux plus hautes fonctions de
parler de corbillards oui je sais ça
commence très mal quand on commence
comme ça si vous voulez si c'est pour
faire plaisir une centaine de personnes
le savent je comprends mais mais on doit
être au-dessus de ça mais on doit
orienter le débat autrement c'est la
situation du pays ne l'empêchera pas
d'aller viser la 6e la situation dans
lequel le ps a mis le pays qui est très
grave
ce n'est pas une rhétorique sur un
corbillard qui est grave ce qui est
grave c'est le le salaire de nos
concitoyens ce qui est grave c'est
l'avenir qu'on propose enfin le nom à
venir du coup qu'on propose à nos jeunes
ce qui est grave c'est les petites
pensions de retraités c'est ça qui est
grave monsieur ce n'est pas le
corbillard qui est grave c'est de l'état
dans lequel le parti socialiste a mis la
france aujourd'hui ce mode agressif et
quand même plus plutôt dangereux on l'a
on l'a vécue il ya peu de temps aux
états unis je crois qu'on a on n'a pas
besoin d'eux dans la société
d'ailleurs mélenchon manifesté hier
contre la lutte des comptes les
violences pardon policière je crois
qu'il faut faire attention aussi au
verbe et au langage qu'on peut employer
dans la société dans laquelle on vit je
pense c'est primordial sincèrement oui
il me semble surtout qu'il faut de la
bienveillance effectivement de la
cohérence pour ce projet commun alors
vous notamment monsieur obama que
beaucoup ce qui a été fait notamment
sous le gouvernement hollande claire
rocher aussi est-ce que vous rejetez
tout d'un bloc c'est à dire toutes les
mesures qu'a pu prendre françois
hollande voulait rejeté tout un côté oui
oui pendant les cinq années de son
quinquennat
les classes populaires elles en ont pris
plein la tête et on sort nous ça compte
pas pour excuser moi j'ai pas entendu le
comte pénibilité ou ce genre de choses
qui ont été mis en place le mariage pour
tous certaines mesures comme ça on est
et s'il ya bien une chose qu'on a pu
dont on a pu faire l'expérience c'est
que on avait beau élire quelqu'un qui
disait mon ennemi c'est la finance au
lendemain de son élection il cédait au
diktat de la finance pourquoi et ben
parce que c'est un combat à mener il
rejette cette accusation lui oui bah
écoutez il rejette peut-être cette
accusation mais les patrons eux ils ont
pas rejeter les 40 milliards du cicr ils
les ont empoché ils ont embauché 00
personnes grâce à ce contrat emploi
compétitivité
voilà
le résultat pendant les classes
populaires c'est une situation qui s'est
encore aggravée et bah écoutez on a fait
cette expérience que il suffisait pas de
trouver un sauveur suprême
moi je suis pour que les travailleurs et
ben ils tiennent compte de cette
expérience et qui se disent mettons en
avant notre politique nos intérêts nos
exigences de travailleurs un travail
pour tous
ça devrait être normal il ya largement
les moyens de les financer en prenant
sur les profits des entreprises
1800 euros minimum de salaire c'est un
minimum c'est pas nous qui lavons
décrété c'est ce qu'il faut pour vivre
voilà ça c'est des exigences qui sont
indispensables pour les travailleurs à
l'heure actuelle et votez pour nathalie
arthaud ça veut dire affirmé que ça ça
doit passer avant les parachutes dorés
des pdg avant les dividendes des
actionnaires avant les fortunes de la
bourgeoisie et ça on est les seuls à
l'affirmer cette élection nous couler
quand on peut converger sur un certain
nombre de points est de faire quelque
chose avec lesquels nous sommes
entièrement d'accord avec vous sauf que
vous me dites pas que ce sera un combat
est donc vous préparez davance a cédé
aux exigences se cherche et là sur les
mots avaient dans l'idée vous avez beau
essayer de toujours vous mettre en
opposition et cetera
vous savez que c'est faux et vous savez
qu'il ya un certain nombre de
convergences notamment pendant pour
comme re nationaliser certaines
entreprises comme edf sur certains
points nous sommes tout à fait d'accord
avec vous mais vous vous tous les
toujours positionnés en position des
seuls 2 de l'ue de de cette unicité vous
soyez de ceux incarnés mais c'est faux
c'est fatigués vous qui faites partie
entre guillemets des frondeurs ce qu'on
a hâte et les fondeurs est-ce que vous
rejetez tout aussi avec l'eau du bain
bien sûr bien sûr que non ce serait
ridicule d'ailleurs vous aurez
d'ailleurs des soutiens de françois
hollande c'est pas besoin des soutiens
c'est s'y reconnaître ce qui a été fait
vous pouvez pas rejeter l'accord 21 et
les accords qui ont été signés à paris
vous pouvez pas rejeter la priorité qui
a été donnée à l'éducation nationale
avec 60000 postes créés vous pouvez pas
rejeter le comte pénibilité vous pouvez
pas acheter le comte formation tout au
long de la vie vous pouvez pas rejeter
l'encadrement des loyers dans les zones
tendues
vous pouvez pas racheté fait la liste
est longue la loi sur la transparence de
la vie pour la panique ont entendu de
votre part vous ne pouvez pas bien sûr
que si bien sûr que si vous ne pouvez
pas acheter non plus la loi sur le
non-cumul qui va s'appliquer dès 2017
pour autant et d'ailleurs j'ai bien aimé
la
intervention de benoît hamon devant les
parlementaires la semaine dernière la
méthode c'est de concerne en priorité ce
que la droite veut casser ça faut pour
le mariage pour tous ça vaut pour le
prélèvement à la source
ça vaut également pour pour être dans
l'actualité quelque chose qui vient
d'être votée tout récemment sur le
numérique et les lives et j'ai enfin
voilà donc ne pas tout rejeter en bloc
pour autant ne pas reconnaître les mêmes
erreurs et je le répète venoix mans a
quitté avec arnaud montebourg le
gouvernement pour des accords sur la
ligne économique c'était clair ne pas
commettre les mêmes erreurs et les deux
grandes erreurs de cette fin de
quinquennat c'est quand même la loi
travail notamment la version 1 et la
façon dont elle a été abordée avec
brutalité
comment le sens qu'ils ont d'eux mêmes
sans concertation excusez moi sans
concertation avec les partenaires
sociaux sans même concertation avec les
parlementaires et puis surtout je pense
à la loi contre la déchéance de
nationalité qui est une erreur politique
majeure
claire mal à vous quel regard parce que
alors les écologistes ont les avions les
a pas vus à cette action rentre et
d'autres qui sont sortis et non je crois
qu'on a été très clair pour nous sommes
forcément pour les téléspectateurs
chez europe europe ecologie les verts si
après il ya une scission bon maintenant
voilà des écologistes qui sont partis de
façon très minoritaire voilà pour nous
c'est quand même le quinquennat des
promesses non tenues c'est un échec pour
jour c'est un échec
il a tourné le dos à l'écologie et je
veux rebondir sur la com 21 donc
effectivement on a eu la com 21 mai
après quand on voit qu'on ne met pas les
moyens pour avancer sur la transition
écologique et la lutte contre le
changement climatique
nous on ne se contentera pas de mots on
a aussi besoin d'actes derrière voilà si
votre candidat ce matin et s'il est élu
pour vous quelle devrait être la
première priorité sa première action en
fait la priorité c'est d'engager la
sortie du nucléaire
avec une sortie du nucléaire en deux
minutes en 2035 et fermetures d'asseoir
et fermetures et fermeture des premiers
réacteurs dès 2017
j'étais fatigué si benoît hamon face en
mai prochain
oui quelle devrait être sa première
priorité
la priorité c'est la réflexion comme je
vous ai dit tout à l'heure au tour du
autour du travail et la conception qu'on
peut avoir du travail sur pas plus
travailler mais mieux travailler la
réflexion qu'il engagera également dès
le lendemain de son élection c'est bien
évidement tout la question écologique et
la question sociale ne pas les opposer
les unes aux autres et puis c'est la
réforme institutionnelle à travers la
réforme institutionnelle on voit la
place du sénat à laquelle il réfléchit
mais c'est aussi toute une réflexion
autour de donner plus d'importance au
parlement moins d'importance à ce qu'on
appelle aujourd'hui cette espèce de
monarchie qui règne en france donc on
voit bien mais c'est pas spécifique à
benoît hamon on boit bien que chez les
candidats qui sont ici sur le plateau il
ya une vraie volonté de réfléchir sur
nos institutions et l'évolution de nos
institutions
on sent bien qu'on est au bout d'un au
bout d'un système tu bien sûr il ya la
réflexion sont sur les pratiques
politiques sur la transparence de la vie
publique
voilà cette loi était votée sur la
transparence de la vie politique il ya
peu de temps suite à l affaire que zac
et j'ai envie de dire c'est tant mieux
on doit réfléchir collectivement à la
façon de faire de la politique la
politique là où envie faire de la
politique mais faire autre chose après
aussi avoir un manque d'habitude un vrai
statut de l'élu avoir un seul mandat
d'exécutif pour se consacrer entièrement
à ce mandat et je crois qu'on doit ça
aussi à la population pour restaurer un
peu aussi l'image de l'élu de l'élu dans
ce pays j'entends j'entends monsieur
green ou dire qu'il ne faut pas faire
les mêmes erreurs
il ya 394 député part du parti
socialiste qui sont aujourd'hui investi
plus de 80% sont les mêmes donc comment
allez vous faire pour faire cette
nouvelle politique avec les mêmes
personnes donc moi ça j'aimerais juste
comprendre monsieur hamon va bomber le
torse et froncer les sourcils et demandé
à ces personnes là de faire l' inverse
de ce qu'elles ont fait pendant cinq ans
donc tout ça c'est juste un cirque
ridicule
ensuite effectivement concernant
l'écologie il me semble que monsieur
hamon a proposé 50% de nucléaire et 50%
d'énergies renouvelables nous on propose
100 % de d'énergies renouvelables
exactement
on propose aussi 100% de cantine bio
dans les cantines pour nos enfants on
propose la règle verte ne pas prélever à
la terre plus qu'elle qu'elle ne peut
produire notre progrès
et très écologique je sais pas si vous
l'avez j'espère que vous l'avez constaté
on doit ça on ne le renie pas aux verts
qui ont fait ce travail là en amant de m
au coeur des projets l'écologie mais
déjà depuis 2012 monsieur mélenchon
avait mis au coeur de propos de son
programme l'écologie tout le monde
l'appelait vert que vert parce que
l'écologie devient dominante en fait à
gauche et recompose peu refonder la
gauche c'est vraiment le message qu'on
souhaite faire passer
donc je vais redévelopper aussi puisque
on note sa propre proposition c'est pas
que de sortir du nucléaire
une des premières mesures qui me semble
aussi fondamental pour engager la
transition écologique en france et en
europe
c'est d'engager un grand plan
d'investissement de 600 milliards
d'euros par an fléchés sur la transition
écologique et la rénovation la
rénovation énergétique la santé et les
infrastructures de transport du
quotidien l'écologiste se bat pour une
préoccupation de nathalie arthaud si ça
allait bien sûr mais vous savez en
écologie comme dans le reste le problème
c'est que tout est fait en fonction des
profits d'une minorité et tant que ce
sera l'argent qui déterminera les choix
dans l'économie
effectivement on ira dans le mur nous on
pense justement que une société elle
devrait servir à satisfaire les besoins
des gens et en priorité de ce qu'ils
produisent toutes ces richesses donc des
travailleurs et c'est pour ça que moi je
m'adresse aux travailleurs pour leur
dire que dans cette élection
on va leur faire croire que l'enjeu
c'est de changer de président que le
changement viendra par là non on aura
des combats à mener au lendemain de
l'élection quel que soit le président
qui sera sorti des urnes et le seul
enjeu c'est de renforcer notre camp et
de faire entendre le camp des
travailleurs et ses intérêts en votant
pour nathalie arthaud
alors ce sera votre conclusion en
quelques secondes est droite et gauche
veut dire encore quelque chose pour vous
parce que beaucoup de candidats récuse
ce clivage maintenant vraiment en
quelques secondes pour moi oui ça veut
dire quelque chose je pense que la
gauche aujourd'hui c'est quelque peu
perdu au vu des dernières politique
menée que il faut un programme fort il
faut une 6ème république
il faut que les citoyens détermine cette
6ème république et qu'il faut absolument
qu'on restaure les institutions ça ne
peut
partir d'eux des citoyens ça existe
encore la gauche
bien évidemment bien évidemment on le
voit bien dans les propositions de
benoît hamon autour de l'éducation la
culture des propositions très forte
autour de la valeur travail je l' ai dit
tout à l'heure
donc oui il ya un vrai un vrai clivage
on doit affirmer slippage d'autant plus
quand on voit les propositions de la
droite violente
en ce qui concerne bien sûr la baisse
drastique du nombre de fonctionnaires en
ce qui concerne la tâche aux afficheurs
je tiens à saluer surtout l'ouverture de
benoît monde donc la main est tendue
mais aussi ont battu robin ça se passe à
la société civile je voudrais laisser 10
secondes à clairval à infléchir sa mère
si ça existe robert je vais être
iconoclaste et innovantes pour pour nous
aujourd'hui la fracture elle est entre
eux productiviste écologistes merci vous
pourrez tous d'avoir accepté notre
invitation ça passe très vite je vous
rappelle que vous pouvez revoir à cette
émission sur notre site internet ou sur
notre page facebook
prochain débat consacré à l'élection
présidentielle dimanche prochain à 11h30
tout de suite placé à l'info régionale
avec arnaud le feb dimanche en politique
continue juste après francis letellier
reçoit jean pierre raffarin
bon dimanche à tous
[Musique]